- [Instructor] Block A, with mass M,
sits on top of block B,
with mass 2M in an elevator.
The elevator is moving
downward and slowing down.
All right, when we have
this diagram over here,
it's moving downward and slowing down.
So that means it's accelerating upwards.
The magnitude of the
Earth's force of gravity
on block A, is F sub G sub A.
The force magnitude exerted
on block A by block B
is F sub A.
And the force magnitude
exerted on block B by block A
is F sub B.
How do the force magnitudes compare?
This is fascinating.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out
on your own.
All right, well let's just
draw a free-body diagram
for block A.
So,
I have block A right over here.
Now there's a couple of things we know.
We know that this whole
system is moving downward
and slowing down.
And we know that 'cause it says
the elevator is moving
downward and slowing down
and block A is sitting on block B
is sitting on the elevator.
And so if you're moving
downward and slowing down,
that means that your net
acceleration is upwards.
Which tells you that
your net force on block A
needs to be upwards.
Which tells you if we have some forces
that are acting upwards,
the magnitude of those are gonna be larger
than the forces acting downwards.
So for block A,
what are the forces that
are acting downwards on it?
Well, the force of gravity
is acting on block A.
And that's that right over there.
That is, its magnitude
is capital F sub G sub A,
and what's the upward
force acting on block A?
Well, they say the force magnitude exerted
on block A by block B is F sub A.
So the magnitude here is F sub A.
So we immediately know,
because we have a net
acceleration upwards,
remember, we're moving down
but we're slowing down.
So it's a net acceleration upwards.
That immediately tells us
that the magnitude of F sub A
is going to be greater than
the magnitude of the
force of gravity on A.
And so we can immediately,
we can get rid of some of these choices.
But they also are comparing F sub B here.
So how can we involve F
sub B in this inequality?
Well, the key here is
in Newton's Third Law.
Whatever force B is exerting on A,
and we know we call that F sub A,
or it's magnitude is F sub A.
A is going to exert
from Newton's Third Law
and equal and opposite force on B.
So this is going to be magnitude,
the arrows are,
this arrow points downward,
but it's gonna have the same magnitude.
F sub B.
So the magnitude of these
two forces are the same.
So another way to think about it is
F sub A is equal to F sub B
by Newton's Third Law.
And since we know that the whole system
is accelerating upwards,
it's moving downwards
but it's slowing down,
we know that this thing is going to be
greater than the force of gravity on A.
And we see that that is
choice B, and we're done.